joining us now as Ukraine's ambassador
to the UK Verdin pristaiko hello to Mr
Ambassador good to see you this morning
um suggestions that the meeting is
taking place face to face in Washington
because there are concerns about a
nuclear attack uh what is your
understanding
first of all I'm quite happy that this
conversation is taking place this new
development especially the drones which
were bombarded in our cities and we we
understand that these drones came to
Russia from Iran this is a new
development we still have to find our
answer so I believe that both of these
topics the nuclear threats and the new
waves of fighting with us especially
terrorist attacks against civilians this
assumption both secretaries discussed
How concerned are we about the
conversation being about a nuclear
strike
we're not concerned that they're talking
about the nuclear sorry because that's
what we hoped for for quite a long time
already and let's not forget that you
can use both of our grand Tours well one
depends and our sovereignty
because we gave up the nuclear weapons
in the first place in 1994. so this is a
very timely conversation I wanted it to
happen like a half a year ago years ago
but at least they are now talking quite
seriously of how we're providing this
promised security to Ukraine in exchange
of the nuclear weapons
yeah how can so no way about what's
happening with your nuclear power
stations
this is something we have to be
considering there are different
dimensions to that first of all if there
are any nations in the world who would
understand because the the the
gravitness of the situation there will
be probably Japanese and Ukraine after
the Chernobyl so we know what we're
dealing with second they are trying to
you know to take off the degrees they're
trying to bring all our electricity
generates in facilities and and
Equipment most of all the most important
the nuclear stations we are second only
to France in Europe in generating the
electricity from nuclear stations so
nuclear is actually core of our
electricity generation that's why they
are targeting the station that's why the
Target and the Transformations and
generation facilities
30 percent of your power has now been
hit were being told what impact is that
having on the people of Ukraine
it's a huge impact and the winter is
coming you know to some extent it is
because around 10 million in ukrainians
already have to to live in the nation
and Frankly Speaking the economy is not
working we wanted to you know we will
lose by the end of this year the third
of our GDP and most of the factories are
not consuming much of the energy so we
managed to you know to balance the
electricity we are having the influx
from the European Union so with the
assistance of our friends and partners
we are coping with the situation but
that's what Russians are actually doing
they're trying to you know bring us down
to the Stone Age
How concerned are you that you won't be
able if this continues you won't be able
to keep your people warm in the grueling
Winters that you face in Ukraine
we are very really really worrying that
this might happen that's why we are
going around the globe and even here
trying to get as many
generators as possible you know to bring
the the worms to Ukrainian houses it's
the enormous task we are talking about
the biggest Nation by size in Europe and
40 40 million people so this is enormous
task for our government so far we're
managing this
okay to me but as far as um as far as
these strikes are concerned it looks as
though you've not been able to do much
to stop them what do you need
we've done like to give you a figures
out of 84 for example the reason it's
like 84 draws we managed to bring down
50 plus so it's the anti-year is is
working quite effectively also you can't
expect that they are attacking from all
three three directions and you can
expect to stop everything so what we
need and that's what we're starting with
the conversation here half a year ago
that we need to close down our skies
either by the planes and we are not
receiving none of them or by anti-air
defense systems which were started to
receive but in some Nations the Western
Nations has given one or two pieces we
cannot separate with such a number I
hope the secretary was will be able to
use his American colleagues will we have
to have heaven to you know find out the
solution for that okay um it's good to
speak to you Mr Ambassador as always
thank you very much indeed thank you